la file est interminable ils sont
plusieurs centaines
impatient de se faire tester dans la
capitale américaine washington
s'inquiète de la recrudescence de
lakovic 19
la prise de conscience d'une situation
hors de contrôle est forte aussi ici à
los angeles où le stade de baseball est
devenu un méga centres de dépistage mais
difficile d'inverser la tendance
dramatique de la pandémie au début du
mois les cas de coved au pays atteignait
les 76 milles au quotidien le chiffre a
maintenant déjà doublé dix jours plus
tard
à ce rythme on dépasserait les 300 mille
cas par jour dans les prochaines
semaines et de deux à trois mille morts
par jour en janvier
cela ferait plusieurs semaines que rien
de substantiel n'est sorti du groupe de
travail de l'administration trump sur le
corona virus de son côté l'équipe
scientifique de joe biden poursuit sa
campagne de sensibilisation un port du
masque alouini mars cap mais elle n'a
aucun accès aux personnes clés comme le
docteur pham chi situation saine
situation à cause du blocage d'un
président qui ne veut pas reconnaître sa
défaite
les démocrates s'impatiente les
républicains a dit il devrait cesser
leurs manigances à propos d'une élection
que le président a perdu et s'occuper
plutôt de la pandémie
en attendant un peu partout les
gouverneurs impose davantage le port du
masque et réimposé des restrictions dans
les restaurants les jim et autres
commerces
la troisième plus grande ville des états
unis chicago a lancé un avis de
confinement pour 30 jours dès lundi il
masque chiasso ti text kevin prend donc
pas d'action de grâce si les invités ne
font pas partie de la famille médias
oasis et iv
bref la situation pourrait être bien
pire qu'en mars et avril derniers ici
frédéric arnould radio-canada washington